>> FEBRUARY 14TH, THE HOTTEST
THURSDAY OF THE YEAR.
IT'S A WHOLE DAY ABOUT SEX,
ROMANCE, AND SEXY ROMANCE.
SO HAPPY VALENTINE'S DAY.
♪ IT'S 8:00 P.M.
ON VALENTINE'S DAY
MY MAN GOT ME FLOWERS
GOT ME LINGERIE ♪
♪ THE DOOR BELL RINGS AND
I'M LIKE WHAT MORE
HE SHRUGS AT ME AND I
RUN TO GET THE DOOR ♪
♪ IT'S A CARD THAT SAYS
YOU'RE MY SIGNIFICANT
OTTER ♪
♪ OH NO NO TO MY BEAUTIFUL
DAUGHTER
MADE A CARD FOR MOM
OKAY WOW ♪
♪ 'CAUSE DAMN, DAMN, DAMN
THAT'S NOT WHERE
I'M AT RIGHT NOW ♪
♪ I DON'T WANNA
THINK OF YOU
IT'S A DAY FOR ROMANCE ♪
♪ I DON'T WANT TO THINK
OF YOU
WHEN GETTING IN THE PANTS ♪
♪ WE'RE ABOUT TO POUNCE
MONEY'S ON THE BED
AND I'M GRINDING WITH HIM
BUT NOW YOU'RE IN MY HEAD ♪
♪ AND I'M BUMPIN'
I'M BANGIN'
I'M BALLIN'
I'M ABOUT TO BUST THROUGH ♪
♪ SO I DON'T WANNA
THINK OF YOU ♪
♪ STAND DOWN STAND DOWN
AND NOW SHE'S
FACE TIMING YOU
STAND DOWN STAND DOWN ♪
♪ I'M AT MY DESK AND
I'M SEXTING MY BOO
TELLING HIM THE FREAKY
DEAKY STUFF WE'RE GONNA DO ♪
♪ HE SENDS A PIC OF HIS
I HEAR A KNOCK AND IT'S MY
FEMALE BOSS CARLEEN
THIS IS BAD ♪
♪ I'M HOLDING IN MY CHAIR
GOTTA SHIFT GEARS BECAUSE
SHE'S HANDING ME A
BIG PINK BEAR ♪
♪ AND WE'RE NOT CLOSE
CARLEEN DO LESS
A QUICK SIDE HUG THEN HOME
AND MAKE A MESS ♪
♪ I DON'T WANNA THINK OF YOU
YOU'RE A VERY LOOSE
ACQUAINTANCE ♪
♪ I DON'T WANNA THINK OF YOU
WHEN YOU'RE DOWN THERE
DOIN' SOME MAINTENANCE ♪
♪ GIVE US USELESS GIFTS
WE'LL PASS YOUR CALL
BUT TELL ME WHEN DID THIS
DAY BECOME A FREE-FOR-ALL ♪
♪ YOUR CARD SAYS I LOVE YOU
AND AGAIN CARLEEN
YOU ARE MY BOSS ♪
♪ SO I DON'T WANNA
THINK OF YOU ♪
♪ STAND DOWN STAND DOWN
CARLEEN YOU HANDLE
THE CHECKS
STAND DOWN STAND DOWN ♪
♪ I DON'T WANT TO THINK OF
THE CARD THAT MY SON
BOUGHT ME ♪
♪ KEEP IN MIND WHEN YOU
HEAR THIS
DADDY CAN'T
REALLY READ ♪
♪ IT SAYS BABY I CAN'T
WAIT FOR TONIGHT
ANOTHER SEXY FORMATION
BUT IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT ♪
>> AND WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL
HAPPEN TONIGHT?
>> WE EAT CAKE MAMA.
♪ CAKE MAMA ♪
♪ I DON'T WANNA THINK OF YOU
I JUST WANNA CURL MY TOES
WHEN MY DENTIST GIVES ME
A SINGLE ROSE ♪
♪ NEXT THREE DAYS
MEANT FOR ME AND MY LOVER
WHY DID I GET THIS LOTION
FROM MY BROTHER ♪
♪ DON'T DO THAT MICHAEL
THE CARDS AND THE CANDIES
'CAUSE I LOVE YOU TOO ♪
♪ I LOVE YOU
BUT I DON'T WANNA
THINK OF YOU ♪
♪♪♪
>> VALENTINE'S DAY IS FOR
LOVERS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU.
THAT'S WHAT BIRTHDAYS ARE FOR.